now as the president has said
even as we continue to prioritize
diplomacy and dialogue we must also
increase readiness
in support of its obligations to the
security and defense of nato and the
security of its citizens abroad at the
direction of the president and following
recommendations made by secretary austin
the united states has taken steps to
heighten the readiness
of its forces at home and abroad so they
are prepared to respond to a range of
contingencies
including support to the nato response
force if
it is activated
as you have heard me describe many times
our commitment to the security of nato
allies and our article 5 commitment
are ironclad
as the president has also made clear the
united states will act firmly in defense
of its national interests
in response
to actions by russia that harm us
our allies
our partners
as part of that commitment the
department of defense maintains
significant combat capable forces
forward in europe to deter aggression
and enhance the alliance's ability to
defend allies and defeat aggression if
necessary the united states also has a
commitment to provide forces to the nato
response force or otherwise known as the
nrf
in the event that nato should activate
that construct as you may know the nrf
is a multinational force made up of land
air maritime and special operations
forces all components that the alliance
can deploy on short notice
wherever needed
altogether the nrf comprises around 40
000 multinational troops
within the nrf is something called the
very high readiness joint task force or
vjtf
this nrf element which is about 20 000
strong across all domains
includes a multinational land brigade of
around 5 000 troops and air maritime and
special operation forces components
i want to provide some facts on these
preparations that will reinforce our
commitment to nato and to the nato
response force and increase our
readiness
secretary austin has placed a range of
units in the united states on a
heightened preparedness to deploy which
increases our readiness to provide
forces if nato should activate the nrf
or if other situations develop
all told
the number of forces that the secretary
has placed on heightened alert
comes up to about 8 500 personnel
we'll continue to provide updates in
coming days
about
uh these decisions um but specifically
this will ensure that the united states
and our commitment to the nrf
uh has is is consistent with their
readiness for uh for rapid deployment
again if activated
in the event of nato's activation of the
nrf or a deteriorating security
environment the united states would be
in a position to rapidly deploy
additional brigade combat teams
logistics
medical
aviation
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance transportation and
additional capabilities into europe
again i want to reinforce that as of now
the decision has been made to put these
units on higher alert and higher alert
only no decisions have been made to
deploy any forces from the united states
at this time
and by say heightened alert in some
cases some of these forces were already
on a heightened posture readiness to
deploy posture and the secretary decided
to make it even more
shorten the tether even more so in some
cases units would go from say 10 days
prepared to deploy now they're at five
days that's not the case for every unit
that is being notified that they're on a
heightened alert some are simply
more ready and and postured that way
than others the idea though is that all
of these units that he is putting on
prepare to deploy will be ready to go on
a shortened time frame
again no final decision has been made to
deploy them
the secretary will continue to consult
with the president and the united states
will maintain close coordination with
allies and partners as we continuously
review our force posture and make
decisions regarding movement of forces
into and within
europe
as always we will remain in close
coordination with allies and partners as
well as nato and other multilateral
organizations as we continue to review
our forced posture as we make decisions
regarding potential movements of forces
into europe and as we review the
disposition of u.s forces on the
continent
okay i think i've remembered all three
so let me try uh
first uh yes the up to 8 500 and i want
to stress it's up to 8 500 again no
decisions to deploy have been made so
this is about getting units on a
advanced heightened alert that doesn't
mean they're necessarily going anywhere
but of the up to 8 500 that i talked
about they are all us-based
um
uh
as and i'm sorry bob your second
question was
are they intended only for the the nato
rapid response force or could they
perform other reinforcement functions
the bulk of them are intended for the
nato response force uh that the vast
majority of but as i also said in my
opening statement the secretary wants us
postured to be ready uh for any other
contingencies as well but the bulk of
them are aligned for the nato response
force and then their third question was
on timing uh i think you know we've been
watching this very very closely i also
said that right at the top uh it's very
clear that the russians have uh
no intention right now of de-escalating
and because
not every one of these units that we are
notifying are in all all of them are not
in a heightened state of alert
it made prudent sense for the secretary
to want to give them as much time to
prepare to be on a shorter tether
as he can just in case again i want to
stress
particularly with the nato response
force it has not been activated it is a
nato call to make
but we have contributions to that
response force as do other nations uh
you know as i said it's 40 000 some odd
strong
our our our contributions don't come
near the 40 000 number other nations are
going to have to contribute as well but
for our part unilaterally we wanted to
make sure that we were ready in case
that call should come and that means
making sure the units that would
contribute to it are as ready as they
can be on as short of notices
as possible but